mais qu'est-ce qui se passe regardez
déclaré c'est obligé d'être pour la
france
non666 dans quelques jours on sera tous
en enfer les gars et bas une guerre au
suivant oh là là je ne vois rien je suis
dans le noir j'ai bien peur que ma vue
m'empêche de me battre au le morceau
donc la vue c'est bon écoutez moi bien
les tire-au-flanc à moins d'avoir un
handicap physique aux parts et moi j'ai
une couille nous avons à faire des
professionnels et manier l'art du
mensonge et du déguisement l'apparition
d'un commando à eux tous seuls des
cracks enlevé l'époque
en même temps ils sont très fort en nous
on n'a rien vu venir
allez on y va on y va